imagine what it says to these students
to when the university does not have the
people protesting violent violently
removed but instead has to evacuate them
as if they were being rightfully
targeted rightfully targeted right so
what does that say to them that they're
not actually there to protect you the
one who's being assaulted the one who's
being you know we saw this in University
of Washington as well so there were
these big basically pramas protests at
the University of Washington and some
students were speak like a Dean was
there and some students were speaking to
the dean saying you know these people
want us dead they want to kill us and
the dean was trying to get the students
the Jewish students who were complaining
about it who were in tears trying to get
them to move on and stop complaining
about it so that the pro terrorist mob
could continue their protest which
they're doing in your live chat right
now by the way oh really oh my God